this was in the book and they all
unanimously said that this and along
with that 15 page
cam okay this is in children's libraries
here in Hillsboro County approved by
that committee unanimously at Plant High
it's in multiple schools there's 10
images of that woman's naked breast in
that book Thank you thank you next
speaker the cop just comes over he even
he seems kind of sorry about doesn't he
he's so ma'am I just I have to take this
down I'm not I'm not allowed to let you
show this smut yeah of course you're not
allowed to to show that
smut naturally
this is wrong for adults to see and it's
obviously wrong for children to see this
is an issue though where the the parents
need to just keep pushing this is a
total winner